listen to this that is the sound of
neurons firing inside your brain and
it's the key to controlling machines
with our thoughts
a brain-computer interface also known as
a brain machine interface is a system
that allows direct communication between
an organism's brain and an external
machine because our brains neurons
communicate via electrical impulses we
can listen in to these signals and
decode them for our use dr. Miguel
Nicolelis is at the forefront of
developing BCI technology by studying
and monitoring the electrical signals of
the human brain his lab was able to
create mind controlled exoskeletons that
translate the thoughts of paraplegic
humans via an EEG cap into physical
movement through the exercise brief
storms so is a way to dismantle active
electrical signals produced by large
numbers of brain cells we're able to
demonstrate that we could read this
brainstorm song rattle monkey brains and
decode some simple motor messages they
were embedded in these brainstorms and
use them to allow these animals to
voluntarily control the movements of
devices just by thinking the most
cutting-edge brain computer interfaces
require direct implants into the brain
dr. Nicolelis works with monkeys who
have moved via these advanced implants
everything from virtual avatars of
themselves on computer screens to a
robot across the world in Kyoto Japan in
this experiment the monkey is using the
scooter to reach the food bowl it only
has to think about moving and the cart
does the rest
the robotic scooter becomes a mechanical
extension of the monkey and it knows
that it doesn't need to move physically
in order to reach the bowl and then
evolved very quickly we were able to
show that we could record the same brain
storms from human patients and as they
evolved we saw that technology would
become the core of a new approach to
treat patients who suffer from
devastating levels of body paralysis the
work being done at dr. Nicolelis lab
shows us that brain computer interfaces
can successfully read and execute our
thoughts whether they are implanted or
worn today other neuroscientists working
with brain implants are also discovering
how to tune in to parts of the brain
related to the senses of touch smell and
even sight the brain is the most complex
biological device that we know in the
universe
it's a moment we understand it we
understand everything the brain is just
Stardust combined into this amazing mesh
of billions of cells interconnected
producing a version of reality in the
near future this technology will enable
amputees to plug directly into their
prosthesis and allow spinal cord injury
victims to move again it's going to be a
while before we map out the entire human
brain because some say our brains are
made up of about as many neurons as
there are stars in the entire Milky Way
galaxy but in the words of dr. Nicolelis
the ones who get the brain outside the
physical limits of the body the limited
imagination
check out more episodes of cyborg nation
by subscribing to the Wired Channel
you